>> Laura: AS WE MENTIONED
EARLIER PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID
TODAY HE WOULD BE WILLING TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS FROM SPECIAL
COUNSEL BOB MUELLER.
BUT TRUMP'S LONGTIME CONFIDANT
AND FORMER ADVISOR ROGER STONE
SAYS IS IT A TRY.
ROGER JOINS US FROM
FORT LAUDERDALE TO EXPLAIN.
ROGER, I BET YOU LOVE TEARING
THE PRESIDENT JUST RIPPED TODAY
ABOUT NO PROBLEM, I WILL COME
AND HAVE A CUP OF COFFEE, UNLOAD
MY BURDEN.
HOW COULD THIS POSSIBLY BE A
TRAP, MUELLER WANTS THE BEST FOR
THE PRESIDENT.
HE KNOWS HE'S DONE NOTHING
WRONG.
PRESIDENT'S LOQUACIOUS NURSE,
NEVER A MAN WHO SUFFERS FROM A
PAUCITY OF WORDS.
WHAT IS ABSOLUTELY CLEAR IS THAT
MR. MUELLER HAS NO EVIDENCE OF
RUSSIAN COLLUSION, SO NOW WE ARE
ALL THE WAY CYCLED BACK AROUND
TO THE DISMISSAL OF MR. COMEY.
HE SEEKS TO ENTRAP THE PRESIDENT
IN SOME KIND OF PROCESS CRIME,
PERJURY, OR OBSTRUCTION.
THEREFORE, THE BEST ADVICE THAT
I COULD GIVE THE PRESIDENT, AND
THAT UNDER NO CIRCUMSTANCES
SHOULD HE GRANT MR. MUELLER AN
INTERVIEW.
>> Laura: LAWRENCE WALSH'S
INVENTS INVESTIGATION OF IRAN
CONTRA, THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
THERE, WALSH AGREED NOT TO
INTERVIEW PRESIDENT REAGAN IN
PERSON, THEY SUBMITTED -- THE
PRESIDENT RESPONDED TO THE
WRITTEN INTERROGATORIES AND
THAT'S HOW IT WENT DOWN.
HERE WITH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
STAR, SPECIAL COUNSEL, THEY HAVE
THE VIDEOTAPED TESTIMONY AND SO
FORTH.
IT'S KIND OF A DIFFERENT
NARROW PERIMETER YOU WERE ONLY
GOING TO ASK ABOUT THESE TWO
THINGS.
IN A NORMAL GRAND JURY OR NORMAL
INTERVIEW SETTING FOR A NORMAL
CLIENT, NO LAWYER WOULD ALLOW
YOU TO GO IN, THEY WOULD SAY
WHERE -- WE WILL TALK, BUT ONLY
ABOUT THESE TWO TOPICS.
WHAT ABOUT NARROWING THE
CONFINES OF THE QUESTIONS?
>> TRADITIONALLY IF THE
INFORMATION CAN BE GOTTEN
OTHERWISE, THE PRESIDENT WOULD
NOT BE INTERVIEWED.
A PERFECTLY REASONABLE
COMPROMISE TO AVOID A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS WOULD BE
FOR MR. MUELLER TO SUBMIT
WRITTEN QUESTIONS AND FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO RESPOND TO THEM IN
WRITING.
I DON'T SEE HOW ANY REASONABLE
PERSON COULD DISAGREE WITH THAT.
BUT FOR THE PRESIDENT TO WALK
INTO THE BLADE, AS IT WERE AND
TO TRY TO PRETEND THAT MUELLER
AND HIS BAND OF PARTISAN PIRATES
ARE JUST HONEST BROKERS, HONEST
PROSECUTORS JUST TRYING TO
FERRET OUT THE TRUTH IS
DISPROVED BY EVERYTHING WE KNOW
SO FAR.
NOW WITH AN EXTRAORDINARY NUMBER
OF TEXT MESSAGES FROM THE FBI
GOING MISSING, I'M OLD ENOUGH TO
REMEMBER WHEN 18 AND A HALF
MINUTES OF NIXON'S WHITE HOUSE
TAPES WENT MISSING AND THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA AND THE
LIBERALS WENT INSANE.
WHERE IS THAT OUTRAGE TODAY?
IF NOTHING, THAT PROVES THE
PARTISAN NATURE OF THIS INQUIRY
AND THE FACT THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE UNDER ROD ROSENSTEIN,
WHO I HAVE ADVOCATED THE
PRESIDENT FIRE IMMEDIATELY FOR
HIS CONFLICT OF INTEREST, IS NOT
ON THE LEVEL.
>> Laura: JOHN HUGHES SAID
EARLIER TODAY THE FOLLOWING
ABOUT WHAT THE PRESIDENT SHOULD
DO AND HOW WE SHOULD CONSIDER
>> ACTUALLY THINK
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD WELCOME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO
MUELLER AND TRY TO ACCELERATE IT
BECAUSE AFTER HE'S DONE THAT
WILL WRAP UP MUELLER'S PROBE.
>> Laura: I ASSUME YOU
DISAGREE WITH THAT.
>> SPOKEN LIKE THE NEOCON
BUSH-ITE HE IS.
RECORDS DEPENDING ON THE
IMPARTIALITY AND THE LACK OF
VIRUS OF ROBERT MUELLER.
IT IS A FOOLHARDY PIECE OF
ADVICE.
IT IS A SUICIDE MISSION.
UNDER NO CIRCUMSTANCES SHOULD
THE PRESIDENT GRANT MUELLER A
LET THEM SUBMIT QUESTIONS IN